hi there today we'll look at mix-up
beyond
empirical risk minimization by a Hong Yi
Chang Mustapha sis Yong and dolphin and
David Lopes Pass
so this paper is actually pretty simple
but it introduces a technique that
apparently helps with training
classifiers and it I have it seen it
used in practice so there must be at
least something to it it is ultimately
very simple
so usually you input a data point X into
your neural network in deep learning so
f of X that's your neural network your
known neural network has parameters
theta you get some output Y hat and
along with the X you also have a y:i
true label and then you have a loss
function that compares what you output
with your true label and then you just
try to make that loss smaller you want
to adjust your parameters so next time
you see data point X its output will be
a little closer to the true label Y and
we call this empirical miss empirical
risk minimization because you don't
actually what you think is that your X
comes from some distribution from some
data distribution D like the space of
all natural images or the space of all
of language but what you actually have
is you have a data set of a finite
amount of data that you can put a that
you can sample x and y from and so
instead of your minimizing your true
risk you minimize your empirical risk
the empirical risk minimization right
here now what's the problem with that
the problem is that you can get overly
confident about your data points and
nothing else and that will hurt your
generalization so if you have a data
point let's say right here and another
one right here your network is
basically so this this is a this is
class 1 this is class 2 your network is
going to maybe make decision boundaries
like this and like this where it says ok
here is class 1 and here is class 2 but
it could you know it's very conceivable
that here it says ah here is class 4 and
over here is class 7 and right here
through is class 9 and by the way here
class 4 again so the the empirical risk
minimization leaves everything in
between the data points open now what
this paper proposes is that we should
not only train our our classifier on
these data points but on all the data
points sort of in between the two and
this is the mix of data points so this
data point here might be constructed if
this is a and this is B from zero point
one times B right and plus 0.9 times a
because it's mostly a and it's a little
bit B and now you think what are the
labels here if a belongs to class one
and B belongs to class two then of
course the label of this data point is
zero point one times the class of B
which is 2 plus 0.9 times the class of a
which is 1 ultimately because what you
do is you input a class like class
number two if you want to input this
into a machine learning model you just
you don't just say it's class number two
what you input is a distribution that is
basically has zeros everywhere so these
small things there zero zero zero one
zero and this here is at class number
two so this would be class number one
class number two class number three
right you input a distribution like this
if you want to express class number two
now in our sample right here what we
would input as a label is simply a mix
between class
so 0.9 0.9 of class 1 0.1 of class 2 and
then zero everywhere else so this would
be our label for the data point that we
construct right here this will be our
sorry the top one would be our data
point formally you take two data points
and you mix them using this lambda
mixing factor that'll give you a new
data point that's in between the other
data points and you take the two
corresponding labels and you mix them
accordingly as well and that will give
you the label for that data point and
now your model will learn to basically
smoothly interpolate so you will teach
your model the thing on the left here is
class number one right that's class
number one the thing on the right is
class number two this here is a half of
class one and a half of class two so the
model basically learns a smooth
interpolation where the situation that's
here on top is probably not going to
happen anymore but what it would do is
it would sort of create these ISO lines
around class two and then around class
one where it's sort of smoothly getting
less and less sure about the class of
the data points but on the way it is
always either class 1 or class 2 and
they say that can help the
generalization performance and it's
visible or why right it's just the only
thing that's not it it's not clear from
the beginning is that this kind of
interpolation actually makes sense
because if this means we sort of
linearly interpolate between two images
so if we have two images we just take
half of one and half of the other and
that will be not a natural image it will
be kind of a blurry thing otherwise you
know all our problems would be solved
and we could just linearly classify
things but in any case in practice it
actually seems to help
probably because interpolations of two
images linear interpolations are still
much more like something like a natural
image then any random noise you could
come up with
so they say it isn't code right here
code is pretty simple simply want to mix
the two things and the mixing factor
this lambda here comes from a beta
distribution and they use a beta I
believe of 0.4 or something just want to
quickly show you this is the red line
here so the red line as you can see
mostly most of the time they're going to
either sample the thing on the very left
or the thing on the very right that
means the either sample the first or the
second data point but some of the time
they actually sample something in the
middle and it's it's fairly uniform in
the middle so it appears like a good
distribution to sample from if you want
to sample these mixing coefficients and
by adjusting the the actual number of
alpha and beta here you can determine
how many times you sample the original
data points versus how many times you
sample something in the middle okay on
this toy data set right here they
showcase what mix up can do so in a
classic model you have the orange and
the green data points and blue is
basically where the classifier believes
its class one you see this very hard
border here it's quite a hard border now
you only have two classes here and so
the hard border is sort of a problem in
itself because if you think of for
example adversarial examples all they
have to do is basically get over that
one inch and the classifier is already
super duper sure it's the orange class
right whereas if you use mix up your
border is much much much more fuzzy it's
like yeah it's only really sure here and
out out here everywhere but in the
middle it's sort of like me I don't know
and so that's kind of a more desirable
situation and of course this here works
particularly in this in this linear to
the setting but as we can see the same
reasoning applies to sort of higher
higher layers and higher dimensionality
data points right I have to seem to lost
the ability to zoom Oh No
that's back okay and that's basically it
for this paper this is all they do they
propose this method and then they test
it they say something interesting here
that mix-up converges to the classical
method as off approaches zero so that
would push your beta distribution
basically in the middle all the way down
and you would only sample from the very
left or the very right so you can
smoothly interpolate between this mixing
and the classic method they so their
main results are we apply this to
classifiers and what I like is since
again is also a classifier so the
discriminator is a class fair they also
apply it to Ganz and they outperform
unstable eyes the classic training on
ganz they show that it's more robust
towards adversarial attacks because it's
not so sure about intermediate things
and they generally outperform other
methods but also they do this nice
investigation here where they measure
the prediction error of in between data
and what it means is they say a
prediction is counted as a miss if it
does not belong to Y I or Y J so you
have a sample right here X I in the
sample right here X J and you look at
what the classifier says in between the
two data points so you just interpolate
the two data points and just measure
what the classifier says and whenever
the classifier either says y I or Y J
either either a label of those two data
points you count it as correct and you
only count it as incorrect if it says
something else and you can see here if
you train with the classic method erm
the these errors happen much more often
that's exactly the situation I pointed
out at the beginning where in the high
dimensions it can you know occur that
all sorts of decision boundary
sneak here in between the two data
points and by interpolating between them
during training you sort of much reduce
that you reduce that effect a lot now
this they also say that the gradient
norm of the gradients of the model with
respect to input in between training
data it happens the same thing the norm
of the gradients in the middle is also
much much lower and this yeah this
investigation I find pretty cool I have
to say I have seen mixup in practice so
it might be useful I've read a paper
where they basically say oh it was a big
transfer paper yeah where they basically
say it is useful if you have for example
if you have little data and a big model
so you can sort of regularize the model
and is also useful to know that they did
test this with drop out so we can they
compared it with drop out and the
conclusion is basically that this is
something else than drop out so it's not
doing the same thing drop out of course
it means you drop out some of the data
points in intermediate activations and
that sort of gives you a noisy version
of the data point this here can actually
be combined with drop out which means
that it gives you an additional benefit
you see right here most of the best
numbers happen when you use mix up plus
drop out so it seems to be just an
additional regularization on top of drop
out pretty cool pretty cool
investigation awesome alright so if you
like this I invite you to read the paper
if you liked the video please subscribe
and like and comment and yeah have a
nice day bye bye